اخبار تطورات سريعه بنسمعها عن قضيه
الاغتصاب اللي متهم فيها اللاعب المغربي
اشرف حكيمي واحدث هذه التطورات تصريحات
لحكيمه على لسان احد جيرانه القصه يعني
كده علشان اذكركم هي انه في فتاه تعرف
عليها حكيمه عبر انستقرام وتوجهت لي
الشرطه واتهمت حكيمي باغتصابها في منزله
قرب باريس في الخامس والعشرين من فبراير
والبنج قالت للشرطه انها بتبلغ عن الحادثه
بس وما تبغى تقدم شكوى ولكن القضاء
الفرنسي قرر يفتح تحقيق بسبب نوع الحادثه
وشهره حكيمي وبعدها بكم يوم تم رسميا
توجيه تهمه الاغتصاب لحكيمي واستجوبه
واستجوبه البنت حكيمي من اول يوم على لسان
محاميته بينفي الاتهامات وبياكد ثقته في
العداله وبيقول انه متعاون مع السلطات
وبيقدم لك كل اللي بتطلبه وكلنا كشفنا في
تفاعلكم انه قدم للسلطات سجل الرسائل بينه
وبين البنت على انستجرام بينما البنت ما
قدمتها للشرطه لمن طلبوها منها وقالت انها
مسحت انستغرامها حكيمه كمان في الاتهامات
لوالدته اللي صرحت وقالت انه ابنها اقسم
لها انه ما عمل شيء مثل هذا
والجديد اليوم هي تصريحات اللي حكيمي
نقلها احد اصدقاء طفولته وجاره في الحي
اللي تربى فيه في ختافي فيه اسبانيا واللي
نقل لبرنامج رياضي اسباني انه حكيمي قال
له نصا ما حدث كان مدبرا تم خداعي وصديق
طفوله حكيمي قال كمان انه اللاعب وعيلته
بيعانوا من اللي جالس بيصير وانه الله
وحده يعلم الحقيقه
هذه الروايه كانت صرحت فيها المحاميه كمان
اللي قالت انه موكلها ضحيه ابتزاز في
معلومات متداوله كمان اليوم عن زوجه حكيمي
الممثل الاسبانيه هبه وكل ملتزمه الصمت من
اول ما تفجرت القصه وطلعت انباء عن انها
طالبه طلاق اصلا من قبل الحادث باسابيع
والناس شافت اونلاين انها ولديها كانوا في
اجازه في دبي وقت ما مفروض انه صارت
الواقعه وطلعت الناس من حسابها صوره معينه
نزلت في نفس يوم الواقعه وفيها هبه
والولدين متصورين امام برج العرب في دبي
[موسيقى]